.
>> Tucker: WELCOME TO COX
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT THIS PAS
SUMMER WITH JUST A FEW MONTHS
AGO BEFORE THAT MID TOMB LIKE
SINS.
THAT BY DEMONSTRATION FIZZED
HUGE BROWN FACE THE ECONOMY.
MOST VOTERS VOTE BASED ON THEIR
ECONOMY PER THE U.S. ECONOMY HA
REPORTED TWO CONSECUTIVE
QUARTERS OF DECLINING GDP.
THAT IS A TECHNICAL DEFINITION
OF A RECESSION.
TO QUARTERS DECLINING GDP.
RECESSION.
GO LOOK UP THE ONE USED IN
COLLEGE.
BUT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
COULD NOT ADMIT THAT, IF THEY
ADMITTED THE U.S. WAS IN A
RECESSION, THEY LOSE CONTROL OF
BOTH CHAMBERS OF THE CONGRESS
PARADE, BUT HOW DO YOU LIE ABOU
SOMETHING SO EASILY DEFINED.
YOU JUST CHANGE THE DEFINITION
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY DID PARADE
THEY CAME UP WITH A NEW
DEFINITION OF RECESSION.
DON'T LIKE IT GDP, THAT'S THE
OLD WAY, THE RACIST WAY LOOK AT
HOLISTIC FASTERS IN THE WAY,
LOOK AT THE LABOR MARKET FOR
EXAMPLE.
THE LABOR MARKET.
THEN, IN JUNE, THE LABOR
STATISTICS GAVE A MUNITION FOR
THEIR CASE THE BUREAU OF LABOR
STATISTIC ISSUED A REPORT THAT
SHOWED THE LABOR MARKET WAS
STRONG.
A MILLION JOBS AND THE SECOND
QUARTER OF THIS YEAR.
1 MILLION JOBS.
THAT IS A BIG DEAL, AND BIG
STORY AND OF COURSE JOE BIDEN
WASTED NO TIME IN TOUTING IT.
>> OUR JOB MARKET REMAINS
HISTORICALLY STRONG.
OUR ECONOMY CREATED MORE THAN
9 MILLION JOBS SINCE I CAME TO
JOB.
ARC ECONOMY CREATED MORE THAN
1 MILLION JOBS AND THE SECOND
QUARTER.
COULD GET A MILLION NEW JOBS AN
THE SECOND QUARTER DESPITE
NEGATIVE GROWTH.
WAIT A SECOND, HOW DO YOU GET
1 MILLION NEW JOBS WITH NEGATIV
GROWTH RATE THAT SEEMS LIKE
MAGIC.
HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE?
INSTEAD THEY REPEATED THE WHITE
HOUSE LINE, WHICH WAS THE BLS
REPORT THE BUREAU OF LABOR
STATISTICS STATISTICS REPORT
SHOWING 1 MILLION NEW JOBS.
THE PHILADELPHIA FED DECIDED TO
CHECK THOSE NUMBERS AND THEY
FOUND THE U.S. ECONOMY DID NOT
ADD MORE THAN A MILLION JOBS AN
THE SECOND QUARTER HERE AND SAI
THAT NET ADDITIONAL JOBS WAS
ABOUT 10,000.
THAT IS LESS THAN 1 PERCENT OF
THE JOB GROWTH.
THAT IS NOT A ROUNDING ERROR,
THAT IS A MINOR MATH MISTAKE.
THIS IS LIKE CLAIMING YOU WERE
RICH WHEN YOU WERE ACTUALLY
BANKRUPT, THIS IS A LIBRARY SO
HOW DID THEY GET IT WRONG BY
MORE THAN A MILLION JOBS, HOW
DID THEY CONSTRUCT IS LIKE?
AS OF YET WERE NOT SURE.
THEY DIDN'T JUST HELP JOE BIDEN
THERE WAS ANOTHER PURPOSE.
THESE FAKE NUMBERS ALSO GAVE TH
FEDERAL RESERVE JUSTIFICATION T
CONTINUE RAISING INTEREST RATES.
THE BASIS OF THAT REPORT, THEY
CAN RAISE RATES.
>> TO DATE, THEY RAISE THE
POLICY INTEREST RATE BY MORE
THAN A HALF PERCENTAGE POINT
FREIGHT WE CONTINUE TO
ANTICIPATE THAT ONGOING
INCREASES WILL BE APPROPRIATE I
ORDER TO OBTAIN STANCE OF
MONETARY POLICY SUFFICIENTLY
RESTRICTED TO RETURN INFLATION
TO 2 PERCENT OVER TIME DESPITE
THE SLOW DOWN THE MARKET
RESTRAINS WITH THE UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE NEAR A 50 YEAR LOW, JOB
VACANCIES ARE STILL VERY HIGH
AND WAGE GROWTH IS ELEVATED.
JOB GAINS HAVE BEEN ROBUST.
>> EVERY WORD OF THAT, LIKE A
MONTH THAT JUSTIFICATION IS A
LIE, THERE ARE 7 MILLION
AMERICAN MEN OF WORKING AGE WHO
ARE NOT WORKING WATCHING THE
INTERNET ALL DAY.
SO WHY ARE THEY LYING TO US
ABOUT THIS.
THE EFFECTS ARE OBVIOUS, OR IF
YOU HAVE ALONE, IT'S GOTTEN
ADJUSTABLE-RATE, WATCH A MUCH
MORE YOU'RE PAYING PER MONTH.
BY ARE THEY DOING THIS?
THEY WILL OFFSET THE INFLATION
THAT JOE BIDEN'S POLICIES CAUSED
, BUT THIS IS A HUGE
PROBLEM FOR EVERYONE ELSE,
RAISING RATES WHEN THE ECONOMY
IS FALTERING, PEOPLE DON'T HAVE
JOBS, IF YOU KEEP DOING THAT, U
BECAUSE IN ACTUAL COLLAPSE.
THAT SEEMS THE COURSE THEY PUT
US ON.
EVEN WHEN THE LABOR MARKET HAS
BEEN FLATLINED.
THE BUREAU OF LABOR STATISTICS
THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR.
YOU CAN TRUST THE MOST BASIC
ECONOMIC NUMBERS EVER AGAIN.
TO BASE FUTURE POLICIES ON
PRIVATE YOU KNOW IS WRONG, W